العودة إلى الخارج خلال الحرب الأهلية السورية
أعتقد أنه كان هناك تقسيم
للعمل تم
وضعه بين الإيرانيين والسوريين
حيث كان
الدور الأساسي للإيرانيين في العراق هو
بناء الميليشيات الشيعية
وتركوها للسوريين.
لتسهيل القاعدة الآن لديهم
قادة القاعدة في إيران ، لذا
كانوا يقدمون التوجيه الاستراتيجي
وما إلى ذلك ، لكن العمليات الفعلية تم
التعاقد عليها من الباطن من قبل الإيرانيين إلى
السوريين حتى يهبط مقاتلو القاعدة
في مطار دمشق و  ثم
يذهبون عبر خط الأنابيب إلى العراق
حيث يقتلون الشيعة والأمريكيين وأه
وآخرين الحكومة السورية أبقى نظام الأسد
على نفسه خطوة واحدة بعيدًا
عن شبكة التسهيلات تلك ،
لذا لم تكن بصماته عليها أبدًا ولكنهم
كانوا بالتأكيد  شاركوا في
إنشائه وما إلى ذلك وكانوا يعرفون أنه
يحدث
وكان الإيرانيون سعداء جدًا
للسماح للسوريين بفعل ذلك